how was it that first when you were
getting ready to go have lunch with that
assistant
back then like were you oh rehearsing
dialogue
um you know i've never been good at
pitching i can't i can't i can't sit
there and say
okay now picture this that that's that's
what they tell you to do and i'm just no
good at it
i i tell people what my story is and i
hope they can see what i see
um but that that that first time i was
going in to meet john mctiernan's
assistant
i was scared out of my mind i remember
driving to
uh i think it was to the paramount lot
um and uh and and the whole day was kind
of a blur i mean i walked into the
office
they were in the middle of shooting hunt
for red october and as i was walking
into the office to meet her alec baldwin
was walking out in his naval uniform
and i was like holy crap um
it's all kind of a blur to be honest
but somehow once i sat down with her and
it was just me and her
two people having a conversation all
that went away
and i remembered why i was there and i
remembered how much i want to do this
and i talked about how much i had liked
what mctiernan had done
in die hard and predator and i asked her
how they got their start and
she was actually more than his assistant
she was basically his business partner
and they had made his first film
together she had produced it
so i was asking her how they did that
and i was telling her about my student
film
and it just became a conversation and
the key to this business
is just really getting to know people
like you know they it's a cliche it's
not what you know it's who you know
and that's true so often
i've had meetings where the whole point
is simply to get to know somebody
they're not going to buy the idea i'm
pitching they're not even in the market
for it
but get to know them establish a
relationship so
six months or a year down the line when
you have an idea that might be right for
them
you can call them up and say hey hi how
are you and they'll say yeah hi how are
you
and then i'll say hey i've got something
that really might work for you
so do you think that over the past 20
years since you've been in la
that that's been the key to yourself
what a depressing thought i've been here
that long
but we've known people that have turned
around and been here less time have
given up and there's that famous
harrison ford story
you know the 20 years the house all the
rules right right right right right
so is that the key that the
relationships but also
you must have had work and ideas to back
it up because
just being friends with someone or
having their business card and calling i
don't think is
well right though the relationships are
key to to getting your foot in the door
and to getting your work
in front of the right people but if your
work's no good it
all the relationships in the world
usually won't help you not not always
i've seen some
truly bad material produced probably
because of great relationships
but for somebody breaking in
excuse me for somebody breaking in
you've got to have the work you've got
to be able to back up what you say
you